[Music]
[Music]
right what up everybody happy - another
week another show another day with the
lef koe man so happy to have you guys
back again hope you get you look great I
see you look in the mirror you look
amazing
welcome back and we got a beautiful show
we're gonna have the guest rand gatling
former NFL Network insider that I'm
gonna be honest
he was really honest he what he's gonna
tell you guys about the NFL Network and
how reporting works in the NFL is gonna
really open up a lot of people's eyes at
the end of the show I have a left
conspiracy for you yes I do I have a
conspiracy theory that I think has a
chance to really really be interesting
it's a conspiracy theory about Belichick
replacing Grunk so after the Rand
gatling interview stay tuned for that
just some like news and notes with the
homies and how you guys are living
appreciate Seth Bernstein for help and
launched the reddit for left Co show I
think about like last time I checked
about 90 people had subscribed so going
to that we're gonna do a QA on that
reddit so if you want to go onto that
reddit are backslash left Co show one of
the posts there is a weekly QA people
will put up there some questions and
I'll answer one or two probably on the
Thursday episode of the podcast good to
see that up and running not sure if you
saw this Christian McCaffrey posted a
dunk and I got a text right away from
Devante saying don't make me show him my
dunks
I said Devante you show away he tweeted
them out and I'm telling you we're
working on it
this NFL dunk contest has legs really
big legs
I don't think Davante Adams in Christian
McCaffrey the only two guys that can
dunk in the NFL and I know
bleech report is gonna work our way to
making sure that it is a big-time show
every week I do some news and notes make
sure you guys get caught up on what is
going on a lot of camps are gonna be
starting for the new coaches so right
now we're gonna get you know the Browns
there'll be a lot of stories about
Freddie kitchens we're gonna see Kliff
Kingsbury and the Cardinals and look at
our best coach in the NFL our favorite
coach Sean McVeigh pranking him at
dinner love it but also there was a
trade Jourdan Howard traded to the
Eagles for a 2026 round pick a
conditional pick I had a lot of people
hitting me up about this I do not
believe that Jordan Howard is a top five
running back I don't think he's a top 10
running back but what I do think he is
that everyone's under estimating he is a
motivating game changing and temperament
changing running back for the
Philadelphia Eagles when the Patriots
wanted to put you away
they gave it when the Eagles want to put
you away in the Super Bowl season they
gave it to LeGarrette Blount you know
when the Rams want to put you away they
had Gurley the Patriots were able to do
it in the Super Bowl with Sony Michelle
Eagles didn't have that so to get a guy
on third and one and third and two who's
the number one runner behind this Center
in the NFL last year behind the number
one Center at blocking up the run and
Jason Kelsey I think it gives them a guy
that could help them win games but he
might not give you the 60 yard play a 70
yard play but also he's tough as frickin
nails I mean the quotes from the Chicago
Bears about this guy playing what a
shoulder fallen off it's it's a trade
that I understand from the Bears
perspective it shows you where we are
with the running backs in the current
market but I also understand from the
Eagles perspective it gives you a
hard-nosed fighter at that position I
still think they might draft somebody
but I think it's a good piece to have
two things that you probably didn't see
before we get to ran get linen is
enlightening interview now he's working
with Park stories to executives in the
NFL one is Jim Irsay
and I realized that he may have found
hey Quentin what's up man his perfect
counterpart guys in Chris Balor
so Jim Irsay recently told Chris Ballard
about a very high like ranking but also
a very notorious player and I'm like man
I wonder if this is Le'Veon Bell or
whoever it is he said you go get him
you be aggressive and I have no problem
with that let's get this guy with a
horseshoe on his helmet hurshe then said
that he bet that Ballard said you know
we went to this number and I couldn't do
a gym I couldn't and then Irsay said
Chris is very disciplined in his belief
on how to build a team and it's great to
see him stick by his discipline you know
that in the past when a GM went to work
for Jim Irsay Jim Irsay said let's do it
let's go a hundred miles an hour let's
spend all of this hundreds of millions
of dollars on anybody we want let's
bring him in and now he's finally got a
guy to say no to him because every team
in the past would be like yes let me
spend this money this is what Irsay's
needed all along is it no is somebody
that can go man I love that you'll do
everything for this team mr. Onur
but not today trust me we have a
direction and the nurse they finished up
with we like to keep our gunpowder dry
because you never know when you might
need it I think that Chris Ballard is
currently building an absolute
juggernaut with the Indianapolis Colts
they've only signed five guys this
season offseason they return them
kolinsky to sear Marga's hunt gathers
and Vinatieri they signed two free
agents just in Houston and Devin
Funchess big impactful on third down
Devin Funchess across the middle on
third down
Justin Houston getting after the
quarterback on third down and they still
have about 7080 million dollars in the
cap and not doing what the Raiders are
doing and throwing 5 million to Burfict
here and 10 million in LaMarcus Joyner
they're keeping their own they're
drafting they're building up and they're
gonna use that money when they need it
in the waiver system Irsay finally has
his no guy and I think that's a really
big deal for the Colts the other story
that I don't think you guys saw I know
you didn't see is the bengals vice
president made some quotes that if he
were on any other team he
be front-page news and some people would
go you're a front office person so
here's what he had to say Bengals VP Ben
Freeland when asked why do the Bengals
resign right tackle Bobby Hart you could
tell that it upset him this is what he
said for those who say you shouldn't
have signed Bobby Hart who's gonna play
right tackle who oh maybe I'll draft one
in the third round he'll come on really
you're gonna bet your season on that
then he kind of took a shot at Trent
Brown this is what he said next if
you're not gonna play him tell me who
Trent Brown at 17 million really a
seventh round draft pick let go
essentially by his team really we can't
go to a Walmart and buy off the shelf a
high quality starting right tackle that
doesn't exist in free agency
wait what so now you think that we gotta
go shop for tackles at Walmart and
you're gonna insult my man shred and
brown about his contract oh yeah let's
just ignore the fact that Trent Brown
had a great season with the Patriots but
lately there's more here from Ben we
asked Willie Anderson if he go to a time
machine and come back at age 25 we'd
love to sign him but you have to deal in
your universe of options this dude just
Rick Pitino to his press conference and
told Walker's not gonna come through
Larry Bird's not gonna come through that
door
havelcheck he gonna come but he just
willie anderson is not gonna come
through that door and only because he's
in cincinnati is this not making bigger
news if Gettleman said that you can't
shop for tackles at walmart and i wasn't
gonna pay that guy are you crazy
they would have gone nuts but it's only
because he's in Cincinnati and you want
to know the proof because the Cincinnati
vice-president his name is not Ben
Freeland it's Troy Blackburn but you
have no idea okay
you have no idea because Troy Blackburn
is actually the VP the Bengals he
actually said all those things but I
read it and I was like this is crazy but
that's what it's like apparently to be
with the Cincinnati Bengals alright
let's get to the main man ran Gatlin
former NFL Network insider you will may
remember back in 2016 he was the
reporter that broked jinora shangkun's
contract Brock Osweiler Colet CEO semele
Swezey got a big deal and then all of a
sudden Ram was gone and I was like
what's going on he was beaten rapped
bored he was like number two - after
that year then I see Park stories and I
see the story with jaylen Ramsey and I
see the story with Zion Williamson and I
see the story with Jarvis Landry and I
go this aligns with the show this Eliza
the Lefko show about showing these NFL
athletes and what they're like under the
helmet Randy's going to talk about his
experiences in law how he transitioned
to a reporter and is very very very
honest about his time with the NFL
Network to the homies you know that we
always say don't just look at the news
that is being broken look at the person
that is also breaking the news Rand
doubles down on that now our
conversation with Rankin
I always tell everybody one of our
awesome listeners rod Simba made the
beat he's made all of our music thus far
okay him and the regulator's they get in
the studio they get the live instruments
yeah they said now that it's the left go
show we need something a little bit more
fun I was about to say I feel like this
is very arm brand for you bro yes no I
you know this oh by the way everybody
that is the voice of RAM Gatlin
storyteller him and his amazing wife
Janina I think we could show her on
camera she's cool with that they have
the production is it a production
company Park stories yeah it's a
production company it's it's ever
evolving so we do a lot but yeah
production learning and I found out
about you just from NFL Network and
being a reporter and breaking news and
seeing you break news on top of a
dumpster and all that stuff like I've
seen all those things before how are you
I'm great man I appreciate I'm so happy
you came to New York tonight you know
I'm a big fan
you know we so thank you you know when I
was like social media yeah yeah yeah
like DM Dalat you've never actually met
before this is the first time but that's
the internet that's why the internet
best friends I think
so I think so no it's amazing and I mean
as a reporter you know I used to develop
relationships on the phone sure
primarily right so you'd go like a year
talking to somebody two three hours a
day when you're in it and and then you'd
meet for the first time and it was like
it was always interesting because you're
like hey you know it's warm and at the
same time you're like this feels
different
yeah but yeah man I'm a I'm thrilled to
be out here coche is thrilled to be out
here
can you explain everybody your path how
did you get to this point by the way
I've played clips of your stuff before
I've linked to it if you've seen the
jail in Ramsey mini documentary about
kind of him being a dad and interacting
with his dad and training the Jarvis
Landry one I think those were all over
the place and even in college basketball
your Zion one it's always great when you
can go over a million views on that
that's got to feel pretty darn special
so yeah you've you've been able to be
with these athletes and show their inner
personal lives but how did we get to
this point what was what was your path
yeah a fair question so I don't have a
short answer for you always say this is
me the short answer is Matt long but I'm
gonna give you the it's a podcast yeah I
love it so you know the short answer is
you know I started back in college I
went to the University of Oregon I lived
with football players they were my best
friends and so you know I was the
student you know the one that that
really actually had to pay attention to
his grades because I wasn't going to the
league right and a lot of these dudes
were and so I would also help them get
their grades right like of course I'll
be on I'm like bro you gotta have your
grades right I don't care about that you
have to care about it so let me help you
get it right yeah you know and a lot of
these dudes came from less South Central
Los Angeles were where a bunch of my
buddies were from you know I grew up in
Riverside California
I moved to Portland Oregon but I grew up
in foster care I grew up on food stamps
and so you know I know what struggle is
you could connect to them yeah I know
what that feels like and so you know I
was having to be multi-ethnic now nobody
knows that because I don't it's not
something I usually like lead with right
and I pass you know nobody has any idea
that I'm not I think unless I bring it
up
so I've already lied myself to be
Italian for a long there you go
I think it's AI identity is enormous
yeah it's huge and you know having grown
up in the black community having grown
up without much at certain points in my
life and then with a lot at other points
in my life because I ended up getting
brought in through foster care to what
is now my adoptive family but they're
they're my family like I don't of course
a dot right it's my mom my dad my
brother but they had done very well for
themselves it was like The Fresh Prince
so I'd kind of crossed this bridge if
you will right I went from having not
much living on food stamps in an
environment where there's a lot of
violence comparatively sure and then I
went out to the burbs where the
demographics were completely flipped I
went from being the only white boy in my
high school to being the only you know
white dude that acted black in all-white
school sure and so there were all these
identity things that I had to work
through as a young guy and as I got
older and started getting through the
coliseum with these football players
helping them to cross that bridge as
well was important to me on my growth
you're gonna go to the league
you need to know how to act we're gonna
hit the mainstream like you can't you
can't act in the mainstream the way you
acted at home right and I'm not saying
you have to completely change who you
are no I'm just saying if to be aware
that the new ground rules so that's a
long way of saying you know Park story's
our production company is an extension
of that Janina is an immigrant
she's Filipina she was born in the
Philippines raised for the first few
years of her life in Manila and they
moved to Juneau Alaska where she was an
immigrant in a small community and they
were minorities and so collectively you
know we just have a deep deep passion
for helping those who were not supposed
to succeed to maximize their success
right and and the point of that is that
they get to be beacons of hope and light
for all the kids like us right who are
sitting there thinking to ourselves like
man this situation looks hopeless but
look at them they made it and here's how
they made it through hard work
determination effort and you know we
want to do that too so you know I ended
up when I got done with a college and
with the law school at USC and it's a
top 20 law school you know the
conventional path is you get through
your you go through year one you get an
internship you go through your two you
get an internship at another firm then
you get an offer when you go to work you
make 20
thousand dollars a year and actually
makes you 20 next year you make 214
actually make two cells right late yeah
and you know if you make partner you're
making eight hundred nine hundred a year
at the top of the top yeah really
attractive to a kid who came from
nothing
I think that's attractive to a lot of
people yeah yeah yeah yeah so you know
what ended up happening is it took me
like virtually no time I was like I
worked in you know a couple law firms
and you know bottom I was like yo this
is not for me
this is not for me like you just feel it
this is not for me yeah you know I'm not
gonna be able to be myself I'm not a
suit and tie guy you know and and
culturally they're not large law firms
are not I just call what it is right
they're not diverse places culturally or
from you know an ethnic standpoint so I
was just like even in law schools like
you know it's gonna figure out a
different way to do it so I've always
been very entrepreneurial I wanted to
try out different things and have and
you know through that process I stumbled
into I'd started a consultancy to help
college players navigate the transition
from college to the pros right I got my
law degree now and I'm like oh I know
the agent game I've seen that like my
friends went through it I interned at
agencies when I was in college and so
I'd learned enough about it to be like
man you know if I was 21 and I had to
choose a lawyer a CPA a financial
adviser an agent like how did how am I
supposed to do that how did you know
what's good what's bad who's great who's
not who's lying to your face
sure do you have any idea right and so I
was like I remember I went to the I went
to the Players Association when I was
kind of in the research face and I'm
like hey if I wanted to find out how
many times an agent has been fired and
by whom if I was selecting agent Houck
I'd do that and I'm like oh we don't
keep those stats hmm I mean why don't
don't you think that's relevant like
sure when you want your son or daughter
to know right ifs I've been fired 12
times yeah
or 30 times by and then to be able to
reach out to those players and be like
what happened why did this happen and if
it's just like oh you know I didn't like
him that's one thing it's another thing
like you know I think this dude either
ripped me off or led me to somebody who
ripped me off like don't you think that
that is a material you know element of
making a decision that could impact this
kid's life especially there was like an
association that like looked after the
players yeah sure oh man yeah yeah
that'll take us on a detour any
so so I was very passionate about that
that business ultimately was not
commercially viable because I had a
fundamental flaw in my business model
that was that I assumed that
n-c-double-a member institutions cared
enough about their kids to invest in a
program to help them make that
transition successfully yeah it could
not have been more wrong really could
not have been more wrong
how quickly did you figure that out it
took me a year and a half to finally
give up on it and it was the toy it was
it was the most painful it was the most
painful failure in my life bar nine well
cuz it sounds like everything felt like
it was leading up to that yeah your
experience at college and like seeing it
firsthand yeah like they're going
through the draft and you're going
through law school and it's this perfect
thing where now I get to help and then
oh y'all don't give a [ __ ] right
Yeah right bro it blew me away and I'll
remember I'll never forget bro so I
remember like you know I'm I'm super OCD
like so you can tell you more so I'm
like maniacal about it right so it's
like when I'm in it I'm I'm in it 15 16
17 hours a day I wake up at 5:00 a.m. on
fire
I start working and then you know I go
to sleep when I pass out like 10:00
11:00 at night and I'm working at all
moments in between that we work from
home so like there's no commute there's
no cut off I'm not talking to anybody in
my office you know it's me and Janina so
you know with that like I just learned
so much and I knew that these kids
needed help so I remember sending to a
university I mean bro yo spread it out
there's the University of Oklahoma there
was a compliance guy there and I sent
him an email that said it was I remember
is called million dollar mistakes and I
think it was like Kenny Anderson and
Antoine Walker talking about having you
know I bought mink coats and I was
trying to put my people on and so you
know and I blew through my money but
like I didn't know and I'm like how
would they know they came from the hood
like who was gonna tell who was gonna
tell him yeah you know you say you got a
million dollars a million I'm good no
you're not bro that hundred is fifty
right after agent fees taxes everything
else right then you're gonna get churned
from all other things and then
extrapolate take that 50 and in
basketballs a little bit different
because those guys play longer careers
right right so they make and it's
guaranteed and it's guaranteed yeah so
it's different money but it's
Apple 8:15 sorry fifty million dollars
out over the course of let's say a guy
retires when he's thirty the next forty
years of his life right I'm not saying
it's a small amount of money I'm saying
it's not as much as they think it is
also when like you're living a lifestyle
no one goes you're not playing anymore
so you can't live like that right you
got a downsize they're gonna go no I
work to have this for the rest of my
life right in my family you know cetera
and a lot of these athletes have big
hearts you know they want to take care
of their entire family and they're
trying to help everybody Wow and this
was Antoine Walker so anyway so I sent
this this really moving
I remember the OTL piece to this guy at
Oklahoma and I'll never forget Rowe I
got a response from him
I think I'd send it to a whole bunch of
people and he was on the list and I got
a response from and said box of Kleenex
question mark like this dude is charged
with helping these young men succeed in
life yeah and the comment was dripping
with condescension jealousy and a lack
of basic carer empathy Umbro I was
floored
not only that that's how he really felt
but that this dude was dumb enough to
put it in an email right and send it out
and then five minutes later I got it was
an Outlook you know said I won't say his
name but such-and-such is trying to
recall the message so anyway I say let's
say this you know it's good to see that
honesty though yeah man not for your own
person it was because it helped me
understand like I'm probably fighting a
losing battle here this is back in 2009
2010 so that experience led me to
basically say okay this business is not
gonna it's not gonna win I didn't take
the bar straight out of law school
because I was like I'm gonna do my own
thing I'm gonna go do this
no oh my god what am I gonna do I owe
$200,000 in law owns yeah I'm not
practicing law I'm not making $200,000
and those those offers from those law
firms they're not there anymore bro the
entire law right that the the law
industry or the legal practice and she
had collapsed that year in 2009-2010 it
was done there was no going back yeah so
I'd worked out here that summer at a law
firm in a top 25 global law firm in the
financial
and I'd had an offer it's 160 plus 40
bonus turned it down nope not doing it
so now it's like oh man what am I gonna
do
so I become friendly with as I started
gathering all this in-depth information
on agents financial advisors marketing
guys I had this like very highly
spatially given myself or taught myself
the equivalent of a PhD in the
professional service providers for
professional athletes right wait where
is that valuable no nowhere right except
as maybe a reporter and I'd befriended
some reporters at Yahoo and so I was
like Brougham I'm in a tough spot like I
don't know what to do next I don't want
to practice law I feel like it'd be so
crushing can you get me a job doing what
you guys do
so Charles Robinson at Yahoo was like
you know yeah I think I can help you I
mean ya knew and he was um he was
amazing you know he basically went to
bat for me and I got a gig making twenty
seven thousand dollars a year you know
this as well as I sure New York City Los
Angeles you can't breathe the air for
$27 I was making eighteen five in
Nebraska imagine make it 27 in New York
yeah that's wild yeah I feel like I
spent 20 75 on coffee over the yeah it
was crazy bro and we were in Portland so
it's like a little bit easier yeah yeah
still but that was that bro so I started
I started writing at the intersection of
law and sport for Yahoo and then over
time like it was this evolution like I
went from doing kind of investigative
work trying to trying to basically like
highlight how janky the n-c-double-a is
and was and his yeah and I was like look
if they're not gonna acknowledge that
these kids have value in the market we
have to prove that that market exists so
that they can no longer deny it that was
the force of my work in the beginning
and also analyzing how players were
being separated from their money so I
investigated financial propriety
committed against players we didn't
covered multiple Ponzi schemes multiple
Ponzi schemes really at the time we
weren't calling them Ponzi schemes
because defamation is a very real thing
right as an investigation so if you
accuse someone of that they could come
back and it can be over quit and nobody
knows anything I've never really talked
out loud about it but I'm I'm not in the
industry anymore so yeah I can now talk
about it yeah but yeah bro like we saw
it and so what we were doing is
we'd identified there's a lawyer out of
Miami Florida's name's chase Carlson and
he's phenomenal
he's a securities attorney who
essentially his entire life is going to
get money back for people who have been
ripped off and he specializes in working
for athletes which is a problem in and
of itself right like he recognized that
there was enough there were enough
athletes being ripped off sure that he
needed to specialize in that area in
order to help them get their money back
because if you know all of the players
in the industry we hear who the scammers
are yeah before it it happens right so
we'd identified he and I working kind of
like really hard in our opposite spheres
but sharing information to the extent
that we could when we could to help each
other get further down the road on like
what's really happening here it's weird
too because I feel like it's one of the
few times where there's no public
sympathy like there's this weird notion
that when an athlete gets ripped off
well he should have been smarter with
his money like even I'm watching this
big baller brand stuff right now and
there and everyone's kind of going
that's what Lavar gets and I'm like dude
just [ __ ] him out of 1.5 million like
if you're a really good trusted business
partner did that to you you'd be at the
barber shop or you'd be at the bar like
going isn't this crazy and everyone be
saying wow what an [ __ ] but instead
we're going what a bad dad like it's
weird like we don't when an athlete
loses money it's like that's it's like
we ballon them for having god-given
talents you know like like they didn't
deserve to be that athletic anyway it's
weird so this is why I appreciate and
respect you so much and it's interesting
I so this is the first time I've done
anything on camera yeah really anything
since I left the NFL Network and you
know the reason why it was such an easy
yes for me is because you are an
advocate for players you like ever since
I've been aware of you you've known
riding for players always and I wish
more people would do that I just for me
it's like this empathy thing to and I
don't know if it's because like I've
I've friends with a bunch of them and
like I've met him over time but like
when she also like there's this weird
thing like I I watch the media and they
like always go so hard in one direction
in the
and we paint him out like Odell was
always fascinating to me I'm like here
is this kid and he's being made to be
this like huge creation and I I just
don't ever think anyone looks and goes
he's 25 right like he's a 25 year old
person that if he tweets something out
it will be on SportsCenter yeah if he
posts a video it'll be on house of
highlights right and I just I'm always
fascinated at like they're not all mrs.
Kardashian they're not all these media
manipulators that can like see the
system and know the impact a lot of them
are just normal people that have a gift
and we turn on them so quickly and it's
yeah and I appreciate you saying that of
course and I appreciate you sharing it
but a please can continue with for you
yeah well I couldn't agree with you more
it's gross and it's just real quick
before we move on you know however you
feel about levar yeah how could you not
feel horrible for Lonzo right he was 19
bro like he trusted people around him
and ripped off why is it not like man
this is horrible let's do something
about so to your point we incur these
Ponzi schemes we're letting you know
players know behind the scenes hey man
I've I've obtained promissory notes that
are very troubling for two separate
investments that I know that you have
put money into I know this is jarring
I'm not trying to scare you what I am
trying to do is make clear to you that
we have uncovered enough signs that
these are dubious investment schemes I
was what we had to use before you know
actually saying pot very dubious
investment schemes and there's this
thing on a FINRA so the Financial
Industry Regulatory Authority or some
like that so on their website and all
athletes should know this there's
something that I don't know if they
still have it but back when we were
doing this in 2013 12 something like
that they had something was called scam
check bro it is I'm I'm not kidding it's
like is the promissory is it a
promissory note is it privately yes okay
red flag starts to click up did they
roll over your note yes clicks have a
little bit more is the interest rate you
know whatever it was 20% or more yes
it's a scam like it's not hard
literally just go right and all of these
dudes were some of the players we're
talking to us behind the scenes and
sharing with us like man here are some
of us here that some some of things were
happening this financial adviser was
recruiting me at the strip club you know
he picked me up in a limo drop a big bag
like give me a Gucci bag full of money
you know and then I knew behind the
scenes this financial adviser was paying
intermediaries five ten thousand dollars
per meeting okay just to get to the
player in the first place so you're
looking at you're like okay we're tre
this type of stuff yes
now Pete this is where it gets really
fascinating so okay one of the beautiful
things about the financial advisor
industry is there is a decent amount of
transparency especially when guys are at
we call Raa so they're kind of
independent shops and you can see how
much money they have under management
all right so you go and you say like
okay how much money is this dude haven't
managed me yes let's use easy numbers
for easy math he's got a hundred million
dollars under management all right
how do financial advisors make their
money you get one percent of money under
management okay cool he's making a
million a year
we got a staff of five people plus
himself we're kind of houses he oh he's
in a 7,000 square foot mansion what kind
of car is he drive always got three cars
mazi Ferrari land right and you're like
something is not adding up like if you
got 600 or 500 after your million is cut
down and you got to pay staff yeah like
how are you living like this as a
standalone we're not even getting into
how are you dropping bags on people with
$100,000 or $20,000 of $50,000 right and
how are you giving a dude $10,000 stack
on his way to the strip club yeah in a
limo like how are you in paying $5,000
to intermediary like it doesn't add up
so you're automatically on high alert
like bro something's happening here
right but something is amiss okay
so to your point a lot of people are
like oh that's just you know dumb jobs
they should know better
why and then additionally when you look
at it and you really look at it from
from an empathy focused place you're
like these kids are often very
vulnerable they don't see themselves as
kids and we can use young men to honor
what they're becoming right but the
bottom line is they just are not
equipped to deal with this world that
they're being thrust into and then
cultural norms a lot of these financial
who do this stuff prey upon them because
they know that these are the things that
these kids have been brought up to
believe are the things that they should
seek out that they want that they need
when you're 20 21 years old you can be
lured 20 21 year old red-blooded
American male right you can be lured
into a lot of things that you can't be
lured into when you're 31 Yeah right
exactly if I was a college kid and I'm
getting ready for the draft I would
think that people dropping off bags
would be the norm kind of person I would
think that people telling me that I'm
gonna invest in the next Starbucks or
I'm gonna have like my own chain of
something like this is what comes with
the NFL and then when when my community
comes back to me and they need money
don't worry because I'm investing for my
future and they end up being the biggest
man in their entire community and
they're responsible for so much so even
myself I'm going in the movies yeah give
me the cash drop the bag right yeah and
this is not a secret but having spent
you know I think five years as an
investigative reporter and in doing it
at a very high level three years running
I either authored or co-authored or was
involved deeply in the you know the
research leading to kind of the
publication of the article three years
running we've won in associated Sports
prep associated Sports Editors
Associated Press is a PSE investigative
top-five finish one year we want it one
year we were what were the three stories
about so the first one was so this is
interesting I'll take a step back real
quick I I was co-captain or you know
junior officer sure and so I wasn't
leading I didn't have editorial yeah
authority and so in in retrospect there
are things that I would have probably
myself had I been driving the ship I
would have probably done differently
just because we're my my sympathies lie
but anyway all that being said I the
Miami story was the first one that we
were involved in so the way that came
down grote I I told you had all this
research on agents yeah so I was looking
at agent firings
okay so there's website that's like an
you know the NFL kind of website and
they tracked firings so I collected all
of these firings and then I put him into
my own spreadsheet and basically created
a way to manipulate the data to tell me
oh this agent has been fired this many
times this agents been fired this many
times and so I did it and I and you if
you know the game you know what it is
like if a dude goes into Miami and signs
seven first rounders in two years and he
never had signed a first rounder in his
life Roy was a new agent high likelihood
there's something more to that than him
just being the most effective recruiter
in the world right he's probably just
not the best sales right let's probably
something more going yeah so then you
just you're like okay that's interesting
which is another example of why this
data matters and why you can draw out
insights if somebody cared enough to do
it and so I'd identified this agent who
would done just that he signed a bunch
of players out of nowhere
yeah and they fired him okay well now
you really know something's going on
because if he was the most effective
recruiter in the world and he was most
effective like relationship builder in
the world them cats are not firing him
yeah like that but if something else led
to them signing with that agent then it
is more likely and we're talking in
broad generalities here as opposed to
this particular situation right I'm
being very careful then then it you're
good at tiptoeing I would say yeah well
you know relies on you not not getting
it wrong I gave up journalism yeah man
it's where we're there's so many people
out there that are investigating and
yeah and it's scary bro it is it's
really intense I'll tell you why I think
it's important to us oh let me say this
they and I was as to the homies
journalism is the reason there's a
school in Glen Mills where they were
beating kids for decades and they just
closed the doors yeah like the value of
journalism is insane like your ability
to like save these kids lives yeah I
have moved myself more into
entertainment yes just because I see the
work that it takes that Ryan that it
requires and I know that I'm not going
to be fair like I can just be honest
with myself yeah but what you guys are
doing is invaluable
and necessary well thank you any a man I
mean what I would say is in that
instance what I what I saw where I was
sitting the information I said okay
here's this agent who was clearly doing
something to get these kids in the door
I knew what those somethings generally
were in the industry and then he was
getting fired quickly I wonder who he
ran his business with so I went on son
bids which was Florida's state
registration website you know the law
backer kind of helped with stuff pulled
up the business formation Doc's and this
dude was this particular agent had
started a business with Nevin Shapiro
mmm
they had a sports agency together well
the reason I knew about Nevin Shapiro
the way this all came to be is I read an
article I think wasn't like the Miami
Herald Nevin Shapiro says you know he
was paying players for years and bla bla
bla bla bla and so I'm like and he ran a
sports agency really that's interesting
so that's that's what it was bro like I
knew who this agent was how the firing
patterns look and I just went and I was
like wait they have a business together
so I passed that off to Charles yeah and
then you know at that point I was a
contractor I think or not or I can't
remember what my status was but I wasn't
like a fully fledged member of the team
so he was like this looks really
compelling thank you bro I got it from
here yeah and that was that so you know
I helped wherever the Nevin Shapiro
story that shows yeah and again I didn't
I didn't write a line in that story so
it's like what I would have focused on
and what Charles focused on are probably
a little bit different but he he's a
fantastic journalist very rigorous and
you know he's he's amazing at what he
does but but again we're all different
human beings right so it's like just the
way we approach the way we approached
the way we reported a little bit
different sure so anyway that story
ended up becoming what that story was so
the next story I worked on was with
Adrienne were Janowski hmm and it was
this thing where basically you know
Charles had kind of told the guys
internally hey man this guy's really
good with research and like you know he
not did Sam a traditional journalism
background never done a journalism class
never took a I you know oh it's good to
have the outside perspective yeah so
what was like hey I got this story on
Billy Hunter
at the NBPA do you want it do you want
to work on this with me you know I need
some help research whatever oh yeah you
know I'm a year and a half in or
something and now you're getting
accepted I'm working with loads I'm like
okay what's the story oh I think there's
a nepotism and MEPA you know Billy
Hunter has I believe a number of
relationships that call into question
whether there's nepotism there and maybe
it could be inappropriate because he's
supposed to be an effective steward of
the players money right players Pamuk
cetera so I was like oh this is
interesting you know let's let's look
into it so I did an absurd amount of
research on that pulling documents legal
documents filings you know all that kind
of stuff and you know you can go back
and you can read the article now and we
know how it ended up there was just
throws all right there like it was there
and then whoa because he's so well
sourced you know he really handled kind
of that element of it he did the human
sourcing and I did kind of the doc
sourcing for the most part Wow every
sport screws over his players yeah it's
crazy it's crazy so that was - right so
I went from not even being like it was
by Charles I was on the contributor line
and had nothing to do with writing it
then this thing with was it was by whoa
and I'm on the byline it's me right next
year and and I felt good about it
because it's like at the very least I'm
not saying this is no indictment on
Billy Hunter or or anyone else in his
orbit of our family it was just to say
that if you are the if you're the
president the Players Association this
is the players money that pays you and
the players money that you're a steward
of then there should be some I think
there should be radical transparency
like make sure the players know where
their money is going why it's going
there etc right and so that was it we
just wanted to lay out the truth and let
the truth kind of be out there so that
was that and then the following year we
want something I'm sorry I don't if we
did that year we did another story on
Alabama night I was personal byline
prior to that there was another story I
won't discuss it like basically I helped
out on yeah fish capacity yeah anyway
that was that bro and then here's what
happened I went in to talk to my bosses
at Yahoo and they were like hey we want
to start breaking NFL news and I was
like I mean I've been doing investing
reporting for three years like there are
a lot of people in the representation
world that don't like me you know like
that are afraid of me because you've
been going after right and I was like I
just don't I don't know man like and I
don't know if I want to shift gears like
right I feel like I'm doing work that
matters I'm trying to help these players
take back the power and like and learn
more about how shady these worlds are
and you know all these different things
and you know long story short they were
like listen it's more valuable for us
for you to be breaking in a film you're
gonna break news bro yeah or else and I
was like okay I guess I'm breaking news
now like because I need this job
I walked into that meeting with a letter
of resignation I had a letter of
resignation I was hot for a number of
reasons sure you're battling over
compensation all kinds of stuff and I
was just like you know this is
ridiculous like I've been killing it for
you guys yeah and there was a time I
remember the Yahoo investigations like
when one came out we just assumed it was
true bro it was it was crazy and look
three years running this is not to say I
worked with legends ya know what I mean
Jeff Passan Adrian words and ASCII Dan
Wetzel Charles Robinson like these dudes
are as far as journalism goes yeah creme
de la creme for real and I was a nobody
in the journalism world but I had a
unique skill set and so three years
running three Apoc Awards I was the only
one on all of them right so I'm like I
come from a world where it's hike
if you perform you get compensated sure
I was like okay I've been killing it I
started at 27 like what's good can I can
I get what you know I know what everyone
else is making right for sure I get paid
they were like ya know why you'd
probably build your name or what yeah
and what does that even mean Adam like
what does that mean well not now it's
more like now it's more cognizant I
think when I can look and it's we all
have our brands yeah and it's when you
say like the woge bomb or for sure you
know what people stand for and it's the
amazing thing of what you do is is early
on you do all the back filler which is
the meat yeah you are the substance yeah
but they need that picture and the
name next yeah no doubt no doubt so yeah
anyway that was that so that's how I got
into breaking news okay so now I'm at
Yahoo I'm doing breaking news what was
your first big news break that they were
like man Ryan's gonna kill this for I
remember this story so well so I get a
call on Marshawn all right so I get a
call from a source and he says yo this
is back when Marshawn was uh kind of in
a standoff with the Seahawks he says yo
Marshawn is in Seattle he's agreed to a
deal it's gonna pay between I think he
said 11 and 12 per year but he's got to
meet with Paul Allen first but he's
there yeah and he told me how he knew he
was there so I was like official so I
reported it before I reported it though
I had called oh no that's wrong I did
not report it I called someone in
marshawn's camp right named him I'd like
to buy one yeah and I was like you got a
tip I'd help this guy a lot sure so you
you expect you know at some point it's
gonna be good so I call him hey quick
question
I heard that Marshawn is up to he's
about to sign I want to report this I
just wanted to run it by you real quick
any reason for me not to report this
it's not true he's not there you sure my
I got a good source on this he's not
there bro
and Marshalls camp is so protective of
Marshawn yeah like they hear like
breaking news they're like we don't
wanna be a part of that right which is
look don't respond so I got I got the
facts wrong I didn't call him I texted
him I remember I got the text so so
don't respond right or or say can't
comment yeah anything because dude just
straight-up lied and this is somebody I
had been supposedly you know building
with whatever so you know five minutes
later shefter breaks it Marshawn Lynch
is up in Seattle you know he's got a
he's gonna sign with Paul Allen or he's
got to have a meeting with Vaughn for
signs the deals done right bro I lost my
mind cuz I'm out there like trying to
make it happen you know they won't
compensate me for the investigative
stuff I know these other dudes are
making way more money than right I think
I deserve it too but all good I'm gonna
do it in this world and at the time I'd
like it made sense me like oh wait these
news breaking news are making real bread
yes like seven figures real bread like I
want to be the best
that now you know because I'd always
been about empowering players and so the
investigative stuff I thought was
important to shine light on the darkness
but the breaking news stuff was more of
like a constant dopamine hit right every
day you were like this is great look at
this news retweets are going crazy yeah
whatever
so that was the first thing that I
remember but I had written like a pre
article on it so I was in there right
away on Marshawn Lynch news which out of
nowhere infra like aren't you an
investigator for like what you doing
right that was that so bro then I
started like breaking like consistent
amount of news and she has a unique look
on it cuz I like I just sit there all
day going crazy bro like is it just tech
because we're seeing now the Glazers and
the shifters and these guys opening up
about that life is like yeah and they
talk about it's they're obsessed with it
yeah but they ballon it and they're and
they talk about how it's soul-crushing
and they can't I mean your eyes are
lighting up right now like every minute
of your day I'll tell you I'll tell you
this I this is before you got to had a
phone that was before I got to fo
Network every minute of every single day
I mean Jay could fill you in better than
I could but like wake up and cold sweats
you know you you sleep with your phone
I'm not kidding you bro I used to sleep
with my phone okay so the question is
how am I gonna beat Glazer right how am
I gonna beat shefter these dudes have
been at it for 20-25 years and are
masters of their craft they're really I
have all the owners it's not just the
players owners the coaches they and they
started with these dudes right so
everything I always say every year you
go to Indianapolis for the combine
that's NFL Spring Break mmm right so
cats are out there having a great time
like you know you you meet a young
quality control guy with a team or you
meet a young you know area scout or
whatever and you guys start building and
then 25 years later he's a GM or a head
coach and you're good and you're good
that was your guy you guys have a beer
in Indy you know 20 years ago yeah so so
it's like how am I gonna beat these guys
so I understood what that was basically
what I had to do is I had to map out the
space okay who has access to the most
amount of information that I can add the
most amount of
value to their lives okay no one ever
tell you about this insider stuff yeah
this clearly bumming keep it under
percent fun because it's it's a you know
it's really not that hard at the end of
the day I didn't think it was yeah it
was you needed to you needed to treat
people well you needed to be very very
honest you needed to be prepared to be
screwed over by multiple people multiple
times and keep on going
you got to be willing to be told no or
ignored or treated like you don't matter
consistently but I think most
importantly is you had to choose a side
really yes and what are the sides and
insiders will not address this okay so
tier point because I've always said
there's the player side and there's the
the organization side period is that
simple like I I said this before I said
Joe Xena right now is the players
reporter and shefter is like the owners
reporter and I would even say Glaser is
more of like a coaching reporter or so
like I feel like shefter is like so
imbued with the league but those guys
are definitely more the official and
Glaser I think sometimes can go player -
but Joe Xena feels like the player
reporter she is and she's killing it
with it and people take exception with
it and this is something that's real
fascinating - what I would say about
shefter is and I'll be clear on it he
has always been really good to me and I
have found him to be both in you know
I'm competing with these guys I'm trying
to each after writers respect - there's
respect and I'm trying to I want to beat
shefter because you know his grind a
hundred versus be insane it's you both
wake up holding your phone for sure and
we'd communicated a bunch right and over
time and so I had a tremendous amount
respect for him what I would say about
shefter is I think he does the best job
out of any insider of toeing the line
like yes he's got deep league and in
front office connections and coaching
connect he's got connections everywhere
everywhere but that being said I've
never found shefter to be like heavily
slanted to one side or the other gotcha
okay on the other hand Rapoport right
was somebody who I worked with yeah and
we you know I I always had kind of
issues I always had issues with the way
he reported okay so here's where it came
from
sure I'm now told you my backgrounds
you'll understand why this was the case
okay if it's a 50/50 we got a coin I'm
gonna flip it and it's coming down
either for the player or the
organization in the case of let's say
von Miller
sure there's gonna be you know a million
dollar difference between what he gets
and what the team is able to keep then
I'm gonna report the news in a way that
is objective that is accurate I'm a
lawyer so I know how to work with words
but that is going to be if it is slanted
in any direction more beneficial to the
player than the team how would you do
that okay so I'm gonna give you an
example with the with the Von Miller
specifically it was really fascinating
so I was at the combine okay and I'm
reporting for the NFL Network the first
time I'm doing stand-ups which I was
horrible at I hated like really horrible
at it I'm so good at [ __ ] terrible
at stand-ups yes that's because you
didn't do the trick the traditional
upbringing
through journalism I can do this all day
but as soon as I stare into the black
hole bro I'm like it is bad I will
explain later no lists all the time like
you need to hate the the dot yeah like
it's a dot that I I remember I would
eventually look at it and go [ __ ] you
yeah yeah where I was like you have
nothing like you're nothing like it's
not about thinking about the people it's
just like that right there
you're nothing yeah yeah it takes time
yeah it's just reps on it well this is
why you're a pro and I was an amateur
yeah but like you understand law and I
can like speak about NC double-a
tournament [ __ ] credit but uh but anyway
so you're at the comms I had the comment
I'm getting ready to report right okay
so John Elway walks up on them on the
podium he's in the room with all the
reporters yeah I'm right outside the
room getting ready for my stand-up I had
I had information I can't identify
exactly what but I had like I had it yes
physically I could see it I could read
it this is gonna be what von Miller's
contract what's going on in the contract
situation okay so that way goes up to
the podium okay what happens is the team
consistently tries to float information
behind the scenes and through their so
through their reporters yes
with them that is beneficial to them
okay now the purposes of this
information and we're not talking about
Elway and the Broncos but just generally
general frontal generally is to sway
public opinion to put pressure on the
player because they know that their
emotional and invested right and they do
and the team does this 10 15 20 times a
year this is the players first time and
there's so much at stake right right
because it's their life it's their life
right how do I take care of my family
I've been fighting my whole life for
this I'm risking you know this point CTE
paralysis right like all the things that
we see that these players sure right so
it's a very real and they're windows
small as it is right and for the teams
it's more like business another
transaction so he wants he wants a
million and we want to pay him 750 how
do we get to 750 okay float information
that he's a he's a you know a diva float
information that he's you know a locker
room cancer right all the things we hear
float information that you know he
doesn't know the playbook right so we
hear all this stuff every time what
would you say when when we're seeing
stories come out about a player's
character what percentage of the time do
you think it's coming from the team
itself huge percentage really yeah
someone on the team someone on the team
you know I'm not saying it's coming from
the front office all the time but you
can identify just what like broke watch
these reporters it's not hard you can
tell who their sources are of course
it's simple right so you know at the end
I'm not saying like exactly necessarily
you're like oh that's a team side source
oh that's an agent oh that's a marketing
guy right so so anyway Elway walks up
and he says yeah some to the effect of I
think we've exchanged proposals that was
not true
it was factually inaccurate there was a
proposal sent to them
right and they had not sent one back
they're stalling this guy out right in
the midst of a negotiation right because
that guy they're telling the public that
we're engaging we're talking agent fine
yeah we're going back and forth so it's
gonna be a homegoing I'm not fine at all
kureta answering my correct correct
so this is that this is the end but
can't say that right right and the teams
are chess players bro so that so this
you know he stands up there's polished
he's a football hero and he's saying
yeah you know we're exchanging so
everyone's like oh that's oh he's doing
alright my stand-up was next so he what
he's walking down the podium and then I
go live and
like you know I don't know if I
addressed it head-on but I was like I'm
told that there has been no exchange of
proposals then a proposal was sent to
the Broncos but they've not yet
responded so I'm directly contradicting
what we just heard oh I had an email in
my inbox so fast
from my boss at the time like I was hot
you know whatever he was GM at the team
like and I'm like but it's the truth I
got the documents bro like yeah what do
you mean you know and now I saying
anonymous source cuz I can identify who
my source was is it tough being at the
NFL Network because they are the league
bro at state TV right state TV yeah but
they don't sell it like that it's it's
state TV now now let me qualify okay
because I know that this could I know
where this could go okay there are a lot
of tremendous of course reporters see I
have a tremendous amount respect for
Steve Weiss I really like Bucky Brooks
he was always phenomenal to me mjd is
death right so there are people know all
the guys that work there but like you
know systematic things are created for
system it's state TV like and I'll give
you an example because it's it's again
it is not that difficult right how did
Rappaport and where he's at because bro
he gets information spoon-fed to him
because he will report what the with the
teams yes want him to report okay well
what do they want him to report they
want him to report stuff to harm's
players yeah right yeah I can I be
honest with you Lee's I had heard that
you were being told to give him stuff
and that they were trying to build him
up as the lead NFL reporter well my
experience over there and this isn't
something that you know I've never
spoken about but I lasted 14 months all
right I got out you know as quickly as I
could
it was kind of similar to the law thing
I just knew it wasn't right for me and
the reason was you broke a lot of [ __ ]
in a short amount of time thank you bro
I mean I worked really hard at it yeah
and I'd kind of L tied cracked the code
I knew I knew had it I knew how to do it
yeah there was a free agency period
where it was like I remember going who
the [ __ ] this random guy because like
there was the one free agency and I want
to get back to if I'll never yeah there
was the one free agency where everybody
locked and loaded their tweets
for the tampering period yeah and when
that happened it was like gah gah gah
gah gah gah and I remember it was like
you had 40 of them and like Schaffner
had like 30 but it was like it was the
first time we like to have the opening
tamp open tampering beer and I remember
I was like who the [ __ ] is this Rand guy
I remember being in this office and
being like what the hell is going on
yeah yeah so like I remember that's how
I remember me like like being introduced
to you first time that's awesome well
thank you I mean it was one of those
things where you know I I am I'm
aggressive I'm ambitious I want to be
great if I'm gonna do it I want to be
great right whatever it is
tiddlywinks yeah great and so at that
point I was like bro and that's why you
saw me breaking news on it yeah no trash
can because it was like bro they didn't
I had no office they would consistently
consistently I'd break a piece of news
and they would credit him for it why do
you think that was I know why it was he
was their guy he was the god they wanted
to push for cuz he was gonna tow the
team line I was Pro player right it was
a problem from moment one and then he
had I was brought in by two guys who
after I came in the door left okay so
that's tough in any job right like
within like three months right so they
signed me to a two-year deal they're
like oh we want you to come in here and
compete with Rappaport that's what I was
hired to do right come in here and
compete with Rappaport because we're not
sure he's gonna still be here at the end
year guys's contractor running
concurrent basically so at the end of
these two years he might be on his way
out and you might be the guy so I'm like
for sure competition I'm with that like
mano a mano
let's see which one of us can make it
happen so at first I was trying to be
collaborative and the first story was I
remember as a Dez Bryant story so Dez
Bryant was interested a videotape nah he
was he wasn't no it was he was in the
mists of his contract negotiation okay I
had great sourcing on it right and so I
knew what was going on I went to my boss
at the time and I was like oh here's
what I got he's like who are your
sources this is right when I got there
bro like first couple weeks I'm very
uncomfortable because I don't share some
yeah it's not even customary today well
maybe but again depending on how big the
story is for the north or the outlet if
we were doing investigative stuff yeah
we had to share our sources most of that
almost all the time with at least the
lawyers gotcha
you know before I cover their asses yeah
totally you can't say anonymous with you
like what is it yeah
but investigators also based on
documents right where as breaking news
is really based on your relationships
because you're trusting the person that
told you this for the most part that
they're not screwing you you're not
gonna put something out there you can
get killed for Rattler gets killed all
the time because of this yeah so anyway
long story short as Dez Bryant I knew
what was going on with this deal and and
I went to my boss and like here's what I
got I'm gonna go with it because he said
I had to come to him he forgets what I
was in the beginning and he was like I
need you work with rapport on him
because he's got team side sources all
right
he's talking to he's talking to somebody
with Cowboys right that's hyatt scene
you talk to me sighs okay so I I'm like
I don't want to do this but let is the
olive branch let me see if me and him
team up we can go out there we can beat
shefter yes and that's the goal right
like a former NFL Network employee right
take him down whoo they did dirty right
whoo they did super dirty she's doing
okay yeah he's doing great good for him
so and didn't deserve the way that you
treat so anyway I basically you know
went to Rappaport with it and then he
screwed me he reported it like basically
stole the news out from under me you
know yeah like like deprived me of
credit like it was just wild because of
the first experience right so like there
was a way if it was Schefter shefter
would have been you can notice as he
does us a lot from Joe Cena Anderson and
me yes right he does do that alone yeah
and I've had like issues worth from more
and me yes right and he'll credit the
other person first and like as a
reporter bro that's all you got is your
credit right like yes and it matters
when it comes time to get paid this is
why I don't matter cuz when I go and be
like I need to pay they're like oh you
you didn't you're not the one who was
first on the byline and I'm like uh you
told me I could I gave it to him like us
was going I'm being a good team player
I'm getting penalized so anyway that
happened I was like okay not working
with his do it anymore
clearly a snake yeah not interested all
it takes is one time that was it bro and
he worked remotely he was in Dallas and
I'm in LA so anyway that was that now
it's like okay bro now I'm gonna beat
your ass right every day like you got to
deal with me I'm yeah there's no way
you're gonna beat me at this job period
I don't care that you been doing it long
I mean I don't care that the teams are
sending you information you know
directly because they've been told to
write or any of that you're gonna use
that against you
I'm gonna yeah I'll let you rely on that
and I'll go every other way now
you should go start your insider career
cuz now you got it yeah cuz that's
exactly what it was I was like yells the
way he is state TV period so if you have
something that you want to do to to
benefit a player that is not the outlet
you should be using because I promise
you he will harm you someday if he has
the opportunity to do so
okay now the way he would do that is for
instance I think in the Von Miller
situation I could be wrong but I think
in the bottom Homer situation but let's
just use it as an example
he would he would be the one to float
the team has offered him the largest
contract in NFL history he pretty much
did that with a levy on bail story it
was like they offered him an eighty
million dollar contract and someone else
came out later was like it only has 17
guaranteed for the entire contract but
he never said that correct we know what
it is bro that's [ __ ]
yeah these NFL deals are a loser read
they're no real million is not 80 right
and it never is and so so anyway I
started achieving like tremendous
amounts of success as a result of that
because I basically put myself out there
is I'm pro player and I'm Pro agent
because the agents are one to help the
players right set up their families for
life Adam on NFL Network so it's that
it's like validity period but now again
I'm a lawyer right and you have to be
objective so people don't understand the
other ones people don't understand the
nuance here you know you can be
objective and accurate and still every
reporter don't let any reporter ever
tell you well I'm completely objective
no you're not bro you grew up a certain
way you experienced certain things you
see the world a super way a certain way
you vote for you know one party or the
other life right use it's not just about
what team you grew up rooting for rights
your upbringing and your feeling about
an entire socio-economic background you
know for instance I think Rappaport was
the son of an oncologist who grew up in
Li or something like that I grew up on
food stamps in foster care
all right different ends of the spectrum
Yeah right a Great Gatsby [ __ ] yeah I
mean different ends inspector yeah so
naturally we're gonna we're gonna see
the world a little bit differently so
long story short bro you know I became
very successful very quickly at breaking
news because I became known as somebody
that can be trusted to not absolute
promote the players agenda at all times
in all cases because if the players were
on the players wrong yeah but that if
there was a team saying we've offered
him the largest contract then I would be
the one to say actually it's not the
largest contract here's how much money
has been guaranteed this is why it's not
a good deal for this player here's what
would be a good deal for this player and
because I had the analytical background
I would also go out and I would
naturally I'd look for like Von Miller I
remember I did a three minute piece on
NFL Network or something where I was
like this is why Von Miller is special
it's not just about the sax okay he's
coming off the edge teams I talked a
bunch of team personnel they're like we
have to gameplan for von Miller right in
a way that creates DeMarcus Ware or
turns him into a terror on the other
side right so DeMarcus Ware may be
putting up bigger stats or equal sets
but we're chipping Vonn every time he
comes around the edge right with the
Titan because you have to gameplan for
him and that means DeMarcus as well
DeMarcus is gonna eat right so that's
unquantifiable value right Vaughn is
making DeMarcus better yeah not even PFF
is gonna chart that right so you had to
like it so it was this combination of
like PFF analytical data right and then
like stats this many sacks as many
pressures etc and then also human
sources so I felt like bro I felt like
isn't the matrix like I'd like you know
I figured it out shaved one I cracked
the code bro I was ready so that that
free agency period yeah I crushed it
you're like crushed it and that's
because and I don't say that to be like
a pompous jerk I say it because I did I
busted my ass yeah every day I earn that
you know I treated people well I'd I
told the truth you know I fought for it
and so at the end of that free agency
period the dude that runs you know the
NFL operations over at ESPN who I had
kind of been talking to behind the
scenes because I thought that that was
my exit strategy gotcha
was like yo eye chart this stuff yes
they do they have like the competitions
yeah and I finished second a year Wow
shefter was first I was stuck here was
that 2016 17 yeah something like that
and yeah man I finished second bro like
ahead of you know Rapaport ahead of
Guerra folo also like Gary I was good
dude
and their mentor but I've only heard
good things I like careful oh I know him
very well but but I like him anyway yeah
it was this very fascinating thing right
where like I was like oh [ __ ] this is
crazy like I just did
okay but the whole time they're taking
my breaks and they're crediting him on
the ticker Ian Rapoport says Casey
Hayward signs for X amount of dollars
Mike no heed bro the tweets are right
there yeah 1234 me
12:36 him like how is it not at the very
least making a CO break according to
this guy and Rappaport you know right
happen it wasn't happening bro and I'm
like of course I was former
investigative reporter so I'm taking
screenshots of everything I'm writing
track of it I got proof of it when you
said that's your value proposition
that's that's what allows you to
continue your own career yeah is those
yeah and meanwhile you know of course
I'm like okay great this this guy that I
that I'd like to work for over tspn said
that I finished second this is this is
awesome so anyway that was that okay but
then shortly thereafter and I was making
these issues known internally like I
wasn't just sitting there like hey this
is great you guys are you know screwing
me out of credit consistently like I
know what's happening they put him on TV
to discuss my brakes like I never cared
about TV but I understood that that was
to your point earlier right you got to
build your brand exactly in order and
I'm like at least when I when I get a
win you guys are you guys are I never
got news from the league never yeah
right this is was getting news from
League crazy so if it's in free agency
that news is driven in in many many ways
by the people who help to represent the
players right so that's why I crushed
that okay right when it's like trades
the team knows that first of course so
that's why you'd see other reporters
Rappaport included do very well there
was coaches there are a couple coaching
agents who have the vast majority of the
coaches yes and I hadn't built those
inroads he had so he would kill there so
like they were like I could pick my
spots but free agencies the big stage
yeah so I was like okay I'm gonna aim
for the biggest stage and I'm gonna kill
that yeah so that was that so shortly
thereafter basically you know this this
boss of mine kept doing crazy things so
one thing I'll give you an example
another way that's kind of nefarious I
think though I don't think everyone
means it this way but when I would
report news I would say Von Miller
earned you know whatever was sixty
million dollar deal were you month
however many however much million in
guarantees I get an email from the boss
don't say they earned the deal they
didn't earn it you know
say agreed to or this or that but they
never had a problem somebody saying the
team gave the player right 60 million I
think give them [ __ ] again they're
risking CTA was a CT paralysis right all
these things they're not giving them
anything I've been fighting their whole
lives for this so and it could seem like
an innocent word choice right but it's
over time yes you're projecting a
certain kind of motion yes like I said
it's kind of nefarious again and I don't
think that the people that say um versus
gave her their outlet doors necessarily
doing it on purpose okay but I was very
purposeful I would say earned because I
believe they did so I wrote back I
remember a row back my boss you know I
wish you would stop nitpicking me on
things that are of particular value to
me given all of the roadblocks that you
guys have put in my way or you have put
in my way because this is something that
is part of what makes me good at my job
and ultimately it's good for you I'm
helping you guys yeah beat ESPN which is
the job that's the job rightly take a
step back that's a job we need to beat a
numbers game the zero-sum game hundred
percent so you know I was just like I
was like and you're wrong by the way he
did earn it because it's a it's a
calculation by the team in the market of
what that players value is based on his
past production right and a projection
of what he's gonna be worth to the team
moving forward but at that moment in
time he is earned that deal whether you
agree with that or not is irrelevant
whether he continues to perform at that
clip in the future or not is irrelevant
at that moment in time he earned the
deal period bro they obviously did not
like that and I knew that I was not for
long oh the way you're talking your boss
I would did not think you're gonna last
it wasn't long ago it was not for long
ago and you know as a bold email yeah
yeah I mean look I have a very low
[ __ ] quota like I just you know if
it's wrong it's wrong yeah and if it's
right it's right and and he was wrong
you know not only wrong in terms of the
way that he was analyzing the use of the
world but he was also wrong insofar as
he's perfectly willing to continue to
perpetuate something that harmed players
even if it's in a very small way right
it's me you add it all up but you know
to me again it's nefarious because at
the end of the day if a player gets a
million dollars less that could be a big
big big deal for him in the long run but
for the teams nothing
Stan Kroenke is not tripping a few I
mean no it's fine he could misplace a
million dollars in his loafer and he's
fine he's fine yeah
so yeah man that was that and then you
know shortly thereafter I'm getting too
many more details I was like we had a
frank conversation I was like listen I'm
gonna I'm gonna go I got ten months left
on my deal you know let's discuss how we
can handle this I can either sit here
for the next ten months so we can keep
doing this but we all know it's not
working right or you know essentially
you guys can cut me a check and I'll go
yeah so after some back-and-forth they
were like all right we're gonna cut you
a check so I was like great I got ten
months of runway right I was considering
coming to work here really yeah I was
real high on Bleacher I thought Bleacher
was like you know on an uptick I loved
it culturally I thought I sure bit
better over here yeah then I fit there
and I talked to bleach before I chose to
go to NFL Network so I was this close to
signing bleacher I didn't know yeah and
it just didn't at the time it was like
you know NFL Network is the next step to
yes a hundred percent so I was like I'm
gonna NFL Network but it was it was like
literally like very close um so then
after that you know I was talking to
bleacher report and I'm still talking to
ESPN and ESPN was like hey but we love
you but there's a headcount issue so
this is like September
I left the NFL first week of the 2016
season or 17 season like there's a
headcount issue though and I just
finished second in there yeah right so
if you're a Salesman you sell 100
widgets you get paid 10% on those
hundred widgets right
so 99 widgets you get paid on those 99
so 80 get right so I'm like okay well
wait I'm second I sold more widgets than
this guy who's making 400 right yeah I
sold more widgets than this guy who's
making a million right so I got a fall
like somewhere in between what chef ders
making I'm not gonna dig in his pockets
and yeah I actually don't know 100% but
I knew I had a good idea yes and I'm
like bran like significantly underpaid
at this point like I'm ready to get paid
I've performed same thing yeah no all
right this is not something that makes
any sense to me but okay so what
happened is ESPN says head County so I'm
like does it make any sense I'm I just
killed it like why if you're a free
agent and basketball football
gonna pick you up right or sales or
anyway so I don't idle well as you can
imagine and and so I can so she and I
started talking and I'm like you know
what like let's just tell stories like
let's tell stories away we want to tell
the stories I'm sick of getting emails
from my boss telling me I can't say this
or I can't say that like I just want to
help these players get the most out of
their lives like they deserve that right
and again I'm not saying players are
universally the best human beings or
blameless or without mistake or without
mistake right like there's there's it's
humanity we lost but but at the same
time you know they have a chance to be
beacons of light for so many others and
they have a multiplying effect if they
succeed and they do well and they set a
good example that can impact tens of
thousands if not millions of young men
and women all around the world and that
is powerful sure so I wanted to empower
them to do better so she was like she
was like that sounds good you know what
are you thinking so I was like I'm gonna
go out and sell a series and we're gonna
start a production company she was like
great let's do it right she's crazier
than me because that's her crazy like
wait a second you're making this much
money and I though I was underpaid I was
not not making money right and in and I
was like look just just for now while we
wait on ESPN they said you know we can
talk again at the end of the the season
let's try and do this so right away we
ended up selling a big series and and it
was it was you know at a price point
that I was like wait I just sold a
series that allows me to make the vast
majority of what I was making before
well and I don't have to answer to suits
anymore
right like I'm working with and we see
in this series no no I don't think we'll
see maybe five six years from now people
will I can't really get into that too
much okay it didn't it didn't end up
coming out but it was our first foray
into production it was wild we were
traveling all over the world we were
filming young high-profile guys and
during this really coming of age story
it was phenomenal yeah we really enjoyed
experience it was awesome and but long
story short at that point I'm still
thinking initially like I'm gonna go to
work at ESPN but once we got this thing
I was like wait I'm probably not going
back to work
because we can just do this and and now
I'm not gonna be compensated based on
what somebody thinks of me I'm gonna be
compensated on what I do what we do how
many how many people are willing to pay
us to continue doing what we do right
now etc and so I so that was that bro
like and then we found out later ESPN
laid off all those people after this oh
so they were not biessing me it was yes
they were getting ready to lay off 200
plus people or whatever right so they
did have kind of a freeze and they
weren't expanding necessarily
aggressively or whatever they went
through their downturn yeah so that was
that man I mean that's how we ended up
in the storytelling space and then from
there you know as you mentioned we went
on to do this piece with Xion who's a
phenomenal young man phenomenal family
obviously phenomenally talented but like
we really wanted to focus on how good a
kid he was right you know how good his
folks were how cool his little brother
Noah was you know and just we wanted to
again aspects that really weren't
published so I never seen him doing
dunks and all that stuff we know he's a
freak out like I thought what was great
about the Jalen story is as jaylen year
in and year out it's hey Jalen here's a
list of people [ __ ] on them yeah yeah
and that was like his character his
willingness to that bravado but to kind
of see him there with his family and he
training and realized dudes in a garage
yeah dudes in his driveway yeah dudes in
a field this isn't like some
multi-million dollar like workout
facility this he's not banging heads
with other top NFL players him and his
pops yeah what did you learn about Jalen
in that process man he's such a good kid
sorry good young man he's a kid anymore
young man but um he's just a good dude
and his dad is phenomenal and you know
it was this intimacy we're in Smyrna
Tennessee it's a small little suburb
outside of Nashville and his father was
a fireman his brother Jamal as a fireman
as well follow his dad's footsteps was
also an athlete yeah in college and then
his brother has you know his son and
they all are working out together in the
garage you know this dude was an all-pro
yeah and he's he's the at the time like
the hottest young defensive player in
the league right and
and you know you what you learn about
him real quickly is he didn't get to
where he was because he's a talker
he talks because he's put in the work
he's earned the right to go out there
and if that's a part of his persona and
he always I think there was a story that
they told us where he always thought he
wanted to be in the WWE I really wanted
to be this guy yeah and so that's part
of it that's part of his like that's how
he gets himself hyped up I'm gonna tell
you you can't beat me and then you're
gonna go try and beat me because I just
told you can't beat me I can't let that
happen right and I've got the physical
skill to back it up and oh by the way no
one's out working me yes you know period
and you know there was this it's very
endearing cuz here he is with his father
and his brother and and his nephew and
any and he's he's a he's a man of the
people right like he's not too big for
that and he's recruiting other athletes
Gus Bradley came out and visit him so
that was that and to your point like
yeah we covered in the piece like that
he talks trash but we all know that so
it's like you touch it yeah I talked to
her shears well I talked to us but then
what we wanted people to see his him
playing with his niece's right in the
house how much he loves his mother how
much he loves his father how much they
love him you know how they've all every
single one of them invested in his
success sure right and so that was so
important to us to do and you know it
was one of those things where I remember
you did that whole thread about you know
athletes doing good yeah and I
appreciated that man because like it was
right after there was like these arrests
and there's all these stories and
there's that one part of the offseason
where man we love to make NFL players
seem like pieces of [ __ ] right there all
collectively this like masked Marauder
that just does many things right and
it's all I really did is I just typed in
every team name and I wrote the word
charity afterwards yeah and it's
incredible how many stories pop up yeah
but the problem is is we're not
interested when the team drops off
turkeys and Ryan goes to the homeless
shelter right we go oh that's a local
news story yeah that's in the d-block
yeah that that's right before sports
it's the good but nobody really cares
right but it's the collective right
where you go oh my god yeah have I been
doing yeah and you don't realize okay
these are guys and so much
on these plates and so many people are
coming to them but they still have the
time to do these amazing things right
but you know we'd rather hear about the
crazy stuff right we'd rather hear about
the bad stuff yeah that stuff sells
newspapers but when you can see it in
one stream of consciousness and it's
overwhelming like I'm sure that somebody
went through like 20 of them and was
like we get it yeah all right we
understand what these guys do I don't
think you do
here's 20 more yeah because they need to
know yeah because you just get annoyed
by it because every time I sit with an
athlete I can't talk bad about them like
I have a really hard time because
they're such good people and and you
realize where it's either the pressure
that's pulling them that way or it's one
moment where they had one bad thing and
yet we get to judge them for that one
moment the rest of their lives
yeah it's absurd but everybody else gets
second chances right but for them oh
you're the guy that that hit that person
yeah I drove you never in your life
smooth awesome if I had a camera on me
III got into a fight with a co-worker
when I was a reporter in Nebraska right
dude dude took a phone and threw it at a
girl and I tackled him on a barstool and
it was one of those things where like
I'm in a bar and I have him pinned
against the wall and I'm saliva is
coming out whatever and it was one of
those things where I'm in my apartment
later and I'm going if any one [ __ ]
had a camera on me I'm fired be a rat
I'm done yeah but luckily cell phones
weren't that big back in 20 2009 and I
was okay but like we've all had moments
if you've lived life you've had moments
yeah you're glad people didn't capture
ya I've been on stage freestyling at
four o'clock when a bar is closing and I
said some [ __ ] I probably should miss
that but I'm okay saying it now yeah
because I want to own I want to own my
truth we don't let these athletes on
their truth all right right we want them
to fit in to where they're supposed to
be you know I'm not a role model by
Chuck you have to sometimes stake your
claim yeah to get away with things but I
just wish it wasn't like that at all
yeah well this is why you're gonna keep
winning bro and you know you're young
your star is on the rise
you know
Janene on the way over here and I'm like
I have no idea we're gonna talk about
but I love what Lefko stands for thank
you no it's true and the players are
gonna notice it too man like as you
continue to grow and you know Bleacher
has given you this incredible platform
to be you right and that's one of the
things that's so dope about about this
particular organization you know players
are gonna see that man and they're
looking for safe spaces right they're
looking for for people that are gonna
promote them that are going to look out
for them so what you were saying before
about like NFL sources interesting about
be ours when we started we always be
mone not having NFL rights yeah like
this is what people will notice they'll
hear us talk about plays but we don't
show the place right because we're not
in bed with the league where I'm at Fox
we're not CBS right we don't paint we're
not NBC we don't pay all this money I
look at the opposite way I don't have to
answer to anybody
right I don't have the league calling
and saying you probably shouldn't say
that about Robert Kraft you probably
should I could say whatever I want right
and and to me that's freedom yes and and
if it's not being able to show you guys
you know the difference between a three
four and a four three you just have to
let us try and explain it a little bit
right it's a it's a trade-off I'm
willing to take yeah you know what I
mean yeah 100% and you and bro you're
great miss the reporter game at all
do you miss waking over the phone do you
miss the cold sweats so okay this is a
really interesting question some answer
it as honestly as I can you know as I
mentioned when you're breaking news like
during free agency that you grow the
dopamine it's are crazy because like you
know I remember I broke Brock Osweiler
von Miller
Casey Hayward Coleco semele like all of
it and I broke Coletti oh someone's
getting a guard deal is worth like 12
million a year yeah there's about ten
million you know at the open of the
tampering period well I worded it in a
way that was like they've agreed in
principle or whatever but people are
like yo you're you're kind of like
hanging out there right are you sure I'm
like yes I'm like it's done right and
then it's right and then Brock Osweiler
to the Texans I believe yeah for the
monster deal yeah I need to miss right
from the Broca's of Texans and and so
anyway you know a bunch of stuff that I
was able to break Jackrabbit to the
Giants you know all these different
things sure and your phone is just going
crazy bro
and you get to just let it sit there and
there's a point where you look over and
you're like I did that ha ha ha
feels [ __ ] great you know what's
crazy is my phone was never ever on the
table because it was constantly in my
hands really [ __ ] you charge because
you can't let go I so I'm on the west
coast okay
shifters up right three hours earlier
right like 4:00 in the morning so I was
waking up at 1:00 a.m.
cuz I'm I'm not about to sleep until now
I gotta be up when he's up yeah some up
at 1:00 a.m. on the west coast I'm in
office you know it's like the skeleton
crew you know the you miss what you miss
the dopamine a little bit you missed
that and you miss and you hit it also
gives you a drive it gives you like a
purpose yeah it's like a one singular
focus break news yeah it's real simple
and you exist in that Lane right and
thus when you're out of it everything
else is glory but that is that's it
there's constant there's constant
feedback right it's like you're
constantly fighting to do great things
and then when you do something that
people deem to be great they're letting
you know that it was great right and
you're like damn this is dope like I
feel I feel like I'm being finally I
told you my history at Yahoo's now you
know why I like I like you know push
down push down push down and all of a
sudden it's like I fought to get to this
point where reporting is reporting is a
one-on-one sport it's blood sport right
like it's me in this other man in the
arena yeah and he's either gonna beat me
or I'm gonna beat him I was competing
against in my mind I was keeping that
year shefter and rap for those are the
two best guys you know gear fall is a
great reporter but like breaking news
thing was he was good at it sure you're
like he got Odell and it was an honest
person and that that's a year make her
400% but the consistency of the numbers
you're not gonna [ __ ] with shefter right
system policies that he's the goat and
that was the thing so like so so at the
end of the road you know you get done
you say what do you miss you missed that
and then you miss what I miss is being
able to stay in contact with the network
that I've developed as consistently
because I'm constantly checking in with
them hey found this out something I
thought you might want to know you know
think about this let me put you in touch
with this person yeah not just hey man
how you doing right now you're giving
information yeah I hope that you're
gonna get information back right and you
develop and you develop real
relationship stories and one of the one
of the tricks to it for me was it was
never transactional
it was never quid pro quo so I always
tell young reporters and this is true if
I if I was to teach a class on how to
become you know an effective insider
road never show up at somebody's door
asking them for something before you
provide them with something that is of
value to them and not asking for
something in return
right so when somebody pulls into the
neighborhood show up hey vitamin right
provide him with the cake be like hey I
wanted to bring this over for you as mom
my wife maybe you'll like it
and it introduced myself and over time I
hope that you come to appreciate the way
that we treat you you know as neighbors
and maybe then you know we'll figure out
a way to help each other do well in life
but for now I just wanted to drop off
this cake I'll talk to you later
mmm that was it right so it's super
simple provide value to people's lives
well value in the insider game is
information yeah
so I was particularly well situated to
know things that I knew were valuable to
the people that I was trying to develop
inroads for so I was constantly sending
information their way that they valued
and over time you develop a network of
people who are like yo I really
appreciate this it actually is valuable
to me and I know that nothing in life is
100 percent free so let me help you
because otherwise you're gonna stop
helping me and that is true even though
there was no quid pro quo I certainly
was not about to give the information to
this guy who never like for instance the
guy that screwed me over on the marShon
story you get no more help bro helping
you with anything right you know and now
I know you're a liar you know some it's
over you're done with me ya know I'm
gonna focus on these other people who
are good to me and I'm good to them now
you develop these really cool real
relations I miss that I still talk to a
lot a lot of my guys and girls in the
space but it's but it's not as
consistent right and so that you know
that's kind of a bummer because I really
liked a lot of those people but you know
all that being said well how can how can
the homies how can left go show crew how
can they support Park story's like we're
like what can they look forward to like
what do you think yeah man we're always
down for the players and and it's clear
that's where you stand as well I
appreciate you bro so you know we're at
YouTube / Park stories so youtube.com
slash Park story's vimeo.com slash Park
stories face everything right we post
all of our work there the the Kenny
Stills piece that we did
I'm kneeling in the NFL we felt it was
very important to do it's the only piece
to our knowledge that's been done so far
that breaks out why a player that was
involved in the initial protest
continues to protest that is no that's
not on the internet right now we took it
down yesterday yeah I was just looking
for it yeah we made it private because
it's gotten into a number of film
festivals Oh congratulations thank you
and they've asked that you know we keep
it offline until it plays at the
festival so it's good for Kenny right
like he deserves support and so we're
excited for him to be recognized for his
contributions and the things that he's
fighting for and we're working on
something right now on an Iraqi refugee
wrestler who's got a phenomenal
phenomenal story sure we think it'll be
our first feature film so we're in the
process of raising money for that now
our getting started to raise money for
that and you know that's something that
we're really excited by he's not a
notable athlete
but he was born in Karbala Iraq he lived
there for four years had great memories
and then the remainder of his kind of
upbringing was really tough he's taken
to Jordan as a refugee endured all kinds
of horrible things there then he was
taken to Syria and all kinds of horrible
things there then came to the States at
15 years old didn't speak the language
and I couldn't read the language
literally did not know his ABCs and he
missed a ton of school because of all
the trouble he'd had in his life and
long story short he's 24 now he just
graduated from the top honors college in
the country with with you know near 4.0
GPA he's taking 28 credit hours while
wrestling for a top ten program what he
credited me man worked in Congress has
influenced legislation related to
unaccompanied refugee minors so you know
for us it's we've done the the big-name
athlete stuff in order to empower us to
build a platform that allows people to
see what kind of work we do of course
let me come down and then that allows us
to do stories about you know other folks
we just think deserve shine and yeah
there's sports sports like overlap but
we're not just a sports storytelling
shop it's just something that we think
there's a lot of rich stories and a
space of course people want to go watch
our stuff yeah please do you know Zion
in the middle of that March Madness if
you haven't seen that piece yet go check
it out special kids special family if
you haven't seen the jail in peace check
it out same thing special
special family and when this drop so I'm
going to put the the links out there too
so that it's easier for everybody to
find it's funny man cuz I do this thing
left go PR where I saw I saw like D
engine what really start with me is
D'Angelo Russell gets traded to the Nets
yeah he puts out a video at like I'm
working out at 3:30 in the morning and I
was like anybody can do this
yeah you could just say you're working
at a certain time and yeah the whole new
cycles like can you believe that this
guy's grinding and all that stuff and I
watch all these athletes this year it
exploded yeah this offseason everyone
has a camera crew everyone has like
their own little production thing and
they're all showing themselves working
out Patrick my Holmes is doing this know
Del's got a guy and it's it there but
they're all they're all now showing the
same thing yeah and so this was the off
season of the explosion of workout video
right and then every now and then you
get mixed in like a guy pulling a truck
yeah or like someone doing something
like over the top yeah but from like
people that are actually making content
and that are telling stories yeah you
got to be looking at it and going okay
we get it
yeah yeah yeah yeah now I appreciate
that I'm just curious what the
evolutions gonna be of the whole thing
yeah I think that's I think you're a
hundred percent right right like so one
thing we say all the time is anybody can
get you to 80% right anyway to shoot
beautiful footage and like everything we
go up by a red camera and Arion like you
shoot beautiful footage but we
specialize in getting that additional
20% and that 20% is more heavily
weighted than the first 80% right
because what we specialize in is
unlocking central truths about these
players in there and their struggle and
the beauty in that struggle that allows
people to fall in love with them as
human beings not as players take the
[ __ ] helmet off period man yeah other
people you know anyway I don't know more
than just your 40 yeah I'm in your
benchpress
yes it's important bro you know and when
it's all said and done look this is true
but it's hard for players it's really
hard it's hard because I look at their
instagrams and I see the engagement they
get when they post football stuff versus
the engagement they get versus personal
stuff yeah and all the comments are
about football stuff yeah and they want
that dopamine - yes so they they want to
keep
posting them with the helmet on then
making a tackle because that's the stuff
that gets the most likes right and
dribble yeah play football but they're
doing it to themselves right and they
don't even realize yeah you're right
that you need to kind of have to build
it while you're playing of you not
wearing a helmet and not doing that
stuff yeah so that when it's done you're
not just posting throwback Thursdays
right but it's this weird trap they get
into yeah man and it's it's hard to
break well dopamine's amazing it's
amazing and and oxytocin is another
thing that we learned about anytime you
give somebody a hug oh really
oxytocin say I hope I mean when you get
that an oxytocin so there are these
chemical reactions inside of our bodies
that literally you know through human
evolution have have taught us to do
certain things yes because they make us
feel good right and so you're right but
I'll share this with you we've released
four pieces they've been self released
know cosign no platform push no nothing
just us and the athletes sharing those
pieces 13 million views 60% average
watch times half of the people so 6.5
million people that are pressing play
are making it to the end credits
so these players are getting tremendous
tremendous return from an emotional
perspective but also it helps to build
their brands you know like you ever see
will get to know them so you know for us
like that the thing we're most proud of
is you go read our comments on YouTube
there's like this changed my life like I
want to be a better father because Jalen
and his father have such an incredible
relationship mannes aion
and his family are so incredible it
makes me want to be more like them in
terms of the way that I lead my life I
want to be a better person you know
inspired I so that kind of stuff Rose I
was like really good that's what I want
to continue like providing the people
and and yeah man I mean the other thing
I guess since left kopi ours in full
effect is you know players that are out
there that that wants something
different that are willing to invite
people into aspects of their life that
allow fans and those who didn't even
know who they were in the first place
which is maybe more valuable sure to get
to know them better and to fall in love
with their story the way that people do
with Jarvis the way people do with
Jaylin the way people do with Zion the
way people did with Kenny you know come
find us we're you know we're looking for
players who have broad broad reach
we're not rich people yeah we spend all
of our own money on these on these
pieces at least for now we do get paid
to do stuff for big brands sure a lot of
brand work we've worked for laser
passion project yeah man I mean we
worked for you know d-does Nike
Microsoft you know and that stuff is
fantastic and there's some overlap but
these things are the things that were
like you know we can go out we could buy
shoes we can buy cars we can buy this or
that or we can invest in something that
will be here long after we leave this
planet that we continue to add value to
people's lives and you know I'm lucky
enough to be blessed with a partner a
business partner and a life partner
whose also believes in it yeah it's
awesome thank you bro anything else that
you definitely want to let the people
out there know yeah Adam left go just
got engaged I did I did I did just got
engaged we need to send this Manish out
I'm super super happy for you I know
this is our first time meeting in person
yeah but I wanted to tell you
congratulations no I was excited to meet
both of you guys because this is I'm
gonna go down this road everybody there
I sometimes when you meet couples it
makes me sad yeah because I go they want
it so bad and it's just not a thing yeah
and you don't realize it until you have
it yeah and when you actually have it
it's the dopest feeling ever and I feel
bad sometimes yeah I feel guilty for
being less I came home talk about this
right now I feel guilty sometimes that
I'm with someone that I'm like yo this
is so great and so I I could see it
sense it from your guys social media
like it was like clear and it was poppin
and and it's a respect thing and I want
that for everybody you know I want all
the homies to find their person whether
it's whoever but uh no I mean you're a
great person
likewise bro thank you thank you for
sharing everything of course man thank
you for having us and yeah man I mean at
the end of the day bro we're gonna keep
building we're gonna keep doing you know
things to empower people and do more and
you know we're fans we're gonna be here
supporting you from you know this day
forth and every time I got a play in
here that needs a story to be told I
know where I'm gonna send my guy Nick
give me that music cuz I need rain
Gatlin of course
hit him up on social media is it just a
train get Lancer and then park stories
thank you so much for being here guys do
what you do support them show the love
and
you guys keep kicking ass keep doing you
keep being you why alert you later again
thank you so much Saran Gatlin honestly
a really really good guy I appreciate
the support that he's given me but also
this is a guy that we never even met
before that interview and I know we
talked about it there but he said a lot
of things I could get him maybe engine
trouble and I think he also said some
things that he's been waiting to say for
a long time love Co shows a safe space
all right we're I'm looking for people
to come in here and share their truths
and that's all I can hope for and he
gave me his truth and I appreciate it
Rand a lot for them I mentioned before
that I have a conspiracy theory and what
I'm realizing is you know if Jay Glazer
can get out there and and give his
theories and you know we can have other
reporters kind of say oh I mean if Colin
Cowherd can go you know ooh
Russell Wilson could be going to the
Giants ooh I got one and it's not that
serious
but if it happens I want claim it's now
time for me to investigate my Pepe
Silvia here's my left conspiracy theory
Bill Belichick is planning to replace
Grunk with Shia Williamson telling you
you know I've always been intrigued at
Belichick's love and comfort at
basketball games his adoration was stars
he's always checking out LeBron the man
is so comfortable in a basketball gym
have you ever seen him wear open-toed
sandals at football I think not this is
a man who doesn't take off but days off
but I'll take a bucket of popcorn to the
face at a basketball game but that's
when I realized maybe these aren't days
off maybe this is scouting we're at
Belichick Scout basketball players to
make the transition second-round pick
last year
Duke Dawson and that's what piqued my
attention Belichick is football coach K
Coach K is basketball Bill Belichick
Belichick learned under a hot-headed
head coach Belichick was a defensive
coach that had to adjust to temporary
players and he recently won Super Bowl
number
six well what do you know Coach K also
learned from a hot-headed head coach he
too was a defensive minded specialist
that had to adjust to one and done
temporary players he was going for
number six right now have to sit on
number five if Belichick is gonna cover
the player it's a player coveted by
basketball Bill Belichick this is where
it gets weird Gronk retired March 24th
the same week
Bill Belichick did press he never does
press what press did he do coach case
Sirius XM radio show I know you know
what he said there basketball is great
because everybody plays offense defense
but in our sport there's a division
between offense defense and special
teams it's hard to pull all those
together but for Bill Xan could be the
one that pulls it all together last
November and LSU assistant said Zion
would probably be the greatest tight end
that's ever lived that coach errick
Mateos where did Mateos coach in 2015
Arkansas who was the head coach at
Arkansas at the time Bret Bielema not
sure if you heard Greg Schiano stepping
down you know it was likely gonna
replace him as defensive coordinator
Bret Bielema Rob Gronkowski is gone
Belichick found his replacement it's
Zion so when he puts on that jersey next
season don't be shocked just remember
left go told you this song is absurd
thank you for letting me be an idiot and
do some conspiracy theories you guys are
awesome I love you with all of my heart
to all the homies and the DMS and all
the social at left go show you guys are
great and then to the people that are
gonna be filling up the reddit check it
out put in some questions I will have
some answers right now tentatively I
don't usually do this because I don't
want to get excited and a guest cancels
on me but I want to put the pressure on
him all signs are pointing to Pat McAfee
being in here on Wednesday and then that
episode coming out on Thursday it will
be absurd if the McAfee man joins the
lef koe man
in studio one on one all that coming for
you appreciate you guys listening to the
podcast hit me up as always Nick let's
hear that great music oh oh also I want
to give a quick shout out one Nicki gee
the audio man making it happen behind
the seasons listen to all my craziness
about how I want to change the studio
and all that he's been down from day one
number two Jake Jake is the one that
does the timecodes he deals with edits
he's helping to put this podcast
together I need you guys to know were
the people behind the scenes helping me
out and third Connor Rogers from stick
to football but helping out a ton lately
a man I appreciate you thanks to those
guys thanks to you on the lef koe and we
will holler at you later
[Music]